this episode of answer the internet's
brought to you by manscape more on that
in a minute stay tuned to the very end
to get your promo code for a discount
i'm so scared that one was intentional
[__] you guys you're not allowed to come
to the island with me honestly
and i'm gonna be you're gonna be there
with like a bunch of crunch
and die immediately and i'm gonna have
so many tools
my name is carly aquilino and i'm here
to answer the internet
if you could bang any celebrity but
you'd have to make a sex tape with them
that would go viral would you do it
dwayne the rock johnson
yeah and it's going viral you're out
there mom and grandma and everybody sees
it
[Applause]
if you were born with action figure
hands stuck in the same position forever
what position would your hands be in
um probably like this because i feel
like i embarrassingly do this all the
time that's your move
yeah you got two hands
yeah i would just be like that yeah you
know for sure
smoking yeah all of it i could do
anything like this
you could put it there smoking this girl
just takes
two wait was i yeah
you were like well i need a fist to
survive and a hand to dig you like
no i should be like not the other one
another one
legs to be frozen too i want my arms to
be like this i don't want to even be
able to move my arms
i want them just only in this position
what movie most recently made you cry
oh the movie i always cry to is the lion
king
every time i hate scar what opening
scene at the end of it
the end no the end for sure i mean it's
so sad
he's hanging and then that's not the end
that's the beginning that's not the
opening scene either you're both wrong
that's towards the beginning guys
when is it when mufasa well it's when
mufasa dies but yeah you're right
because then simba gets older you're
right yeah
scar is does he have that bad boy right
he has that bad boy five
he does that's my voice
if you could be any character from a tv
show who would it be
we'll get back to carly's answer in a
second but first feidelberg's got you
covered
it's the answer is easy it's frank
reynolds in the quarantine episode
because hair is disgusting it's where
all the germs are kept no one wants to
suck your dick if it's hairy
no one wants to eat your ass if it's
hairy you need to use a [__] manscape
trimmer get the lawnmower 4.0 and
everything else you need to stay smooth
smell good and keep your partner happy
use promo code internet20 at
manscape.com to get 20
off fran drescher in the nanny
jack already are i mean if i wish
um if you could be a master at one of
the four bases of sex but you'd be below
average in every other base which one
would you choose
i guess i would be a master at kissing
because then you trick people into
thinking that you're good at the other
stuff and then you can kind of just
not be good at the other stuff and it's
too late
you got to get in the door i would just
i would rather be good at that because
then it's kind of like oh gotcha
[Laughter]
usually people end up there they don't
usually get there on their own though
you just cut right to the chase you
you figured it all out pretty fast no
i've thought about it before i have i'm
like what
can i do the least work possible would
you rather live your life
as is or be a billionaire but you have
to blow a dude every day i would
of course be a billionaire that blows
dudes every day
oh it's supposed to be okay yeah
but also no of course what if it's this
like
so let's say it's like you're almost
like you're not marrying the guy but
you're getting the money because of him
what if he's like an
old like would you you would have that's
great i would love to blow bill gates
every day
a billionaire what about a millionaire
yeah i probably would honestly no taxes
taken out
then that's what's important that would
definitely be and then
so just think about on day like 1 000
and bill gates is like here yeah he's
got his glasses
i also would love that i would love that
now i would do it for i was just gonna
say i would do it for free gates is a
single guy do you think you would like
date okay
yeah for sure i would i'm looking for
him everybody yeah
but it's like would you really be bill
gates's girlfriend would you want
bill gates like honestly yes
of course i would no he's like my soul
mate
i love him am i not supposed to think
he's hot i don't understand
what about bezos is it specifically
gates or is it um
okay so if it were like [__] marry kill
bezos gates
zuckerman remember remember that like
photo that came out of zuckerberg
like surfing and he had a a juicy ass
i was like okay
he also said that he wore that much
sunscreen
right he looked like a ghost in the
disguise trying to blend in
yeah yeah he had a donkey for sure so
where are you
okay so i would kill zuckerberg
i would marry i would marry bill
and i would [__] jeff yeah can you still
go to your barber if he's very racist oh
my god the picture on this
uh in your case you know if i were going
to a hairdresser
i think i would feel too weird
especially because girls when you go get
a hair color you get your hair colored
or something you're there for like
hours so it would be like somebody's
trying to initiate you into a cult
i wouldn't be able to do it but your
hair is white but my hair looks good
everyone's like oh my god your hair is
beautiful
right like you're known as like the
comic with the best hair because when
you when you're in the blowout thing
yeah you're just sitting there reading
your mind
i don't think i'd be able to do it i
would have her train somebody else
and be like nobody but you yourself know
in your heart
i don't know it's too long of a time to
sit there
it took too long for you to answer that
you're racist um would you rather live
with your parents for the rest of your
life
or always
or always use toilet paper as napkins
this is hard doesn't mean anything about
that [__] bunch of crunch
and popcorn oh yeah because it's not
it's like you know what i'm saying that
like cheap like scott
you see through right away right and
then you have to use that as a napkin
which means you're always gonna have
like
balled up um
where you gotta live with mama ack yeah
i think i would do the napkin i would do
toilet paper
yeah i just feel like i need my space
you know what three items can
that can fit in a fanny pack would you
choose to bring with you to a deserted
island
see now this is like a trick question
because if you bring your
phone you're not gonna be able to charge
it right because you're on a deserted
island
so you need survival kit type things
in your fanny pack so you would need for
the most part you have ah
there's electricity no no no no
electricity but you don't have to
like these are a little bit so i could
bring stuff that i need to charge
no no no no i can't bring stuff
i would never bring medicine i would die
on the island i don't care
all right like give me an infection just
no yeah you're not getting
electricity not getting electricity okay
i would bring
a fire starter i watch a lot of naked
and afraid
i would bring a fire starter i would
bring
um
you know people are like people would
say like i would bring a compass i don't
care
and i don't know how to read a compass i
don't care where i'm at really so
i don't think that would help me yeah
encompassing
one of the easiest things in the world
to read no i don't understand what it
means
because you want to know why everywhere
i'm facing to me is north
i'm just kind of like north and then if
i'm this way it's north
and i'm all good like the world revolves
around
when people are on 14th street and you
look at 13th street you think that's
north
whichever way i'm facing is north and
when people have the balls to say to me
oh meet me on the north west okay first
of all are you christopher columbus
like don't talk to me like that ever
again say i'm outside of burger king and
i'll know where you're at
it's not put like is this science class
so definitely not a compass um
in a fanny pack probably honestly
what would be another really helpful
thing fire starter you gotta
you need some type of a tie like a tie
like a
rope right to make knots so you can
build a shelter
i don't understand why everybody's kind
of judging
my answer everything they're like making
gifts
at summer camp i'm making
my favorite like candy my vibrator and
like sunscreen no well why would
[Laughter]
[Music]
i thought this was about survival why
would i bring [__] candy i'm gonna
eat it in three seconds
a spear
[__] you guys you're not allowed to come
to the island with me honestly
and i'm gonna be you're gonna be there
with like a bunch of crunch
and die immediately and i'm gonna have
so many
over tools how much money would it take
for you to give up your favorite food
for the rest of your life
it's hard because my favorite food is
just bread
so it's just bread so all breads like
but like so sandwiches are out burgers
are out that's a lot of things
um how often do you just sit there and
eat bread all the time
what kind of breath what's your any kind
um
i like honestly i like just like a loaf
of bread like a baguette
classy up again i mean i know what
you're trying to say but that's not how
you say that
how do you say it because you're from
france what
[Music]
what is it um i would say baguette but i
also think that she might be more right
that they play like in the beginning
it's a it's a baguette it depends on if
you're from france or not i think
yeah this is the first time i was in
french class that's how they pronounced
yeah
wow
very embarrassing very embarrassing
you guys no it's fine no some of us are
from france and some aren't
and that's like how do you say uh in
nintendo the little italian plumber
red guy what how do you say his name
mario he's a real one
what i get [__] roasted every day why
what would it be
oh mario okay that right that's like
very classy mario
mario's gonna eat a baguette if you had
to watch your biggest
enemy [__] the girl of your dreams or
the guy in your dreams
in order for you to marry him would you
do it of course
my biggest enemy is gwyneth paltrow
so she could [__] brad pitt yeah she
already has it's all good
so really think about though then you'd
be watching like let's say
rekindled and you're watching them you
know because x sex sometimes where it's
like yeah but it never lasts it doesn't
matter
they've already done it in your head
forever it's like remember that yeah
right but i would be like okay i get to
marry you
that would be the best i mean what a
treat have fun
i don't care it's brad pitt if you got
ten thousand dollars a day
for every day you didn't masturbate how
many days could you last i could go the
rest of my life
ten thousand dollars a day that's fine
with me and it's just masturbating you
could still have sex
see that's a that's a female luke i know
yeah guys it's like yeah we can but can
we
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah 100 what if you couldn't get off
what about all right no getting off
well so it's reality i think like so
what's your current drowning right
[Laughter]
i think i would wait so if i
did then i would stop getting the money
and you can't resume
i would go the rest i could go the rest
of my life i am saying
let's stack this bread and i don't need
it
i don't need it i promise you i'm fine
it's fine no i would no i would be okay
i would go at least until i saved up
like i'm
i would go and lease until i saved up
like millions of dollars
i would have the nicest [__] i just like
that's really all that's
now she's making money she's approaching
right she hasn't come in
he hasn't come since right that would be
the loophole like never having an orgasm
again would probably be harder than
never
like okay no
i would still be able to save up
millions of dollars i really feel that
way
i feel like what would we reach like can
i tell you it's really just
yeah really i mean no being realistic
i think like one weekend i'd be like
how much is that ten thousand yeah see i
just would be like okay cool i'm just
gonna
like jeff bezos who like this way you
don't have to try and get with bill
gates
ten thousand a day is a lot so i would
do that big thanks to carly aguilino for
answering the internet big thanks to
manscaped for sponsoring this episode go
to manscape.com use promo code
internet20
to get 20 off the lawnmower 4.0 the ball
toner
the crop deodorant the boxers the kit
everything you need to make sure
that you stay smooth and don't have a
hairy dick
all right thanks to carl jacolino for
answering the internet make sure you
leave a comment below to see more comics
entertainers and celebrities that you
want to see on the show
make sure you subscribe and hit the bell
icon
to set notifications
[Music]
i hate this
all right my hair is so [__] bad